we've had this issue if I can determine
the fog of brexit has been with us for a
while and it looks like it's it's
settling in for for a bit and the
principle impact of that has been on
business investment and if I if I
stretch it back to before the referendum
to today
the level of business investment best as
we can tell is about 20 percentage
points lower than it otherwise would
have been without this uncertainty do
you attribute all of that 20 percent to
the brexit yeah yes I mean I'd be blunt
about it yes I could give you a higher
number if I adjust it for the fact that
up until very recently the global
economy has been in much better shape
than we had thought it would have been
if you follow all that would have been a
few years ago and on top of that the
financial sector is in very good shape
the cost of capital is very low balance
sheets are in good position the labor
market is increasingly tight wages are
going up all the conditions for an
investment boom are in place except for
one factor about eight months ago you
said that the risk of No Deal brexit
which most people think is still on the
cards as a possibility you said that
that was uncomfortably high for you how
would you characterize that risk as you
sit in this chair today well that was
back in back in August it felt
uncomfortably high then it unfortunately
proved I think proved accurate I would
say it's you know it's it's alarmingly
high now we're in a situation where the
expressed will of Parliament is for some
form of deal so to put in the double
negative as they've expressed it
Parliament is against No Deal the
government is expressed by the Prime
Minister is against No Deal the European
Union is against No Deal and yet it is a
possibility it is the default option it
end and so No Deal would happen as we
sit here today would happen by accident
it would happen suddenly there would be
no transition what we
just discussed and you have a series and
and the cut is that is a disorder I mean
that by definite it is accidental
disorderly brexit now businesses have
been working since you know and
increasingly in recent months to do what
they can to prepare for that and more of
them have put in place their contingency
plans what we would say about three
quarters of businesses are in that
position today putting your plans in
place doesn't necessarily mean you're
prepared that well it means you're yeah
you're prepared as you can be but but we
also know that the infrastructure again
government has made real progress here
but again the port infrastructure isn't
fully there the customs infrastructure
is and there in fact because it's not
there what the government is going to do
is there's a fancy acronym for it tsps
but effectively not check goods as they
come through come through the border in
the initial months to help mitigate the
effects of that but this is all about
reducing the severity of an economic
shock what we can show what we have
shown and what we could show if in the
event if there were a No Deal brexit is
that the financial system is ready we
have had the system build up their
capital credit to the banks for doing
this we've had them build up liquidity
we have access to all these other
mechanisms that can ensure that the
financial system does its job which is
provide mortgages to people want
watching if they need them alone if
they've got a good business idea keeps
their money safe if it's if it's a with
them and that is why we have done what
we have done there is a limit there
isn't there to the Bank of England's
toolkit you can help very much on the
demand side of the economy you can try
and put money back into the economy and
try getting confidence going again what
you can't help with is a big supply shop
and yeah so when I say that it sounds
like economic jargon but well it's
medicines it means lorries on the m25
what can you do
well that's exactly right what we can't
do is we can't we can't get a single
more lorry through through the Port of
Dover others can help to affect that but
we can't and nor can we fundamentally
change the economics of a business in
Scotland that sells to the European
Union at present on a tariff-free basis
where its product standard is instantly
recognized
so it has frictionless trade with Europe
if overnight it has to pay a large
tariff on those goods which it will
because the Europe will flip to WTO and
there's forget the fiction that that
won't happen the absolute nonsense okay
and needs to be called out well I would
point out that they might want to become
better acquainted with the Secretary of
State for trade who in Parliament has
made the point which is exactly right
which is that it cannot apply unless
both parties agree and secondly unless
you're moving towards guess what a
customs union which I don't think has
been the objective there so some of
these issues need to just be taken off
the table and focusing on the reality of
the trading relationship brexit for a
period of time in the short term will be
a hit to supply in the long term we will
see right in the long term it's a
question and have great faith in this
about the you know the ingenuity of the
British people what new trading
relationships we would strike what
investment would be put in place but in
the short term its first and foremost a
supply hit and the Bank of England can
do nothing about that we have no tools
for that so does that worry you
it it worries me because it it worries
me to the extent to which it's a very
unusual situation and
it worries me to the extend to which if
people would were to assume that the
bank can magically take care of this
issue and and we will do everything we
can to support the economy but since we
can't support supply there is a limit to
what we can do